Oops.
Hold on.
Welcome to Outer Wilds Echoes of the Eye.
Hello!
The theme song I know.
I've been like, I've been sitting here just like, cheering
up.
Listening to it.
Wee!
Babycore!
Thank you for the vibe gift.
Thank you so much.
Two months already.
Let's go!
Thank you, Moth.
And Foxplay, thank you.
Hearing this music, I've got to cry.
I know.
Oh, it's so wet.
Yes, I'm super duper excited to be playing the DLC of Outer
Wilds.
Um.
I saw some people saying like Oh, I didn't see Outer Wilds
on Mint's channel But I have played it before That's why I'm
not streaming it Because it's kind of And I played it kind
of recently It's hard It's a difficult game To replay in a
sense Because Well, I mean just I mean not difficult But,
like, if you've played it, then I think you understand.
Can't really unlearn it.
Exactly, exactly.
I would already know all the puzzles and where to go and all
this and that.
Thank you for the hack on Super Boss!
Thank you for all the fun and for being so kind.
It's always nice hanging out in your streams.
What?
Thank you!
Thank you, Saladizu.
Why?
Thank you so much.
Oh, my goodness.
I'd recommend playing through the base game first, but I got
a feeling that you're smart enough to just start with the
DLC.
I have played it, yeah, so...
Yeah, you would have to erase your memory.
I know!
So I'm a little sad that I already played it, so I can't
stream it here.
But I can do the DLC, so that I have not played yet, at all.
I actually know zero things about it.
And, let's see.
The summary called you an AI.
GW.
Turn off the PC right now.
What's really funny, too, is Outer Wild is a game that...
I only really ever see these comments for Outer Wilds.
of people saying that they can't watch the stream because
they want to play the game themselves or they're in the
middle of playing the game.
So, it's pretty funny, but it is definitely, if you have not
played the game before, maybe you've watched someone play
it, which I guess is okay too.
Definitely one of those types of games though that is so
highly recommended, you know.
Completely valid.
of course of course i had to stop watching someone play it
too to do that too yeah it's um it's totally valid and so i
part of me is just like hmm should i even stream it at all
you know but i also truly enjoy uh sharing these types of
memories with you guys so you know i do choose to sometimes
play things even though the people are like no no know you
should play this and take it in yourself but i also kind of
like you know having our little you know i like having my
reactions and my you know my first time reactions recorded
because you can never take that back you know once you once
you experience something you can never experience it for the
first time again and so if i can watch myself you know in
the future i can go back thinking about her wilds i could be
like how did i react to this you know so she doesn't hate us
um so um actually for this uh i don't know exactly i i tried
looking it up without looking it up um the closest i'll ever
get to playing outer wilds again is watching someone else
experience it for the first time thanks for streaming it for
us ah thank you thanks for the super chat yura mr yura thank
you yeah i feel that way too though right um you can resume
well so i actually re-bought the game because i had the
other i played it before on a different account and i um had
to re-buy the game and um and um uh uh the tlc so um
actually i just played like a little bit of it yesterday so
um i was kind of because i was worried i was just like do i
need to have beaten the game before but it seems like as
long as i have the knowledge i don't have to have it in my
save file um from what i understand
that's correct okay okay good down thank you for the 10
gifted thank you it might change some things wait my ship
log i know i know i was looking at it i was like i was like
oh man i kind of want to do like a summary like wow what
happened everything but if if if you guys tell me that i
must have completed the game in in in the fact that i need a
completed save file I do have access to that so so I don't
oh what the heck OBS just disconnected I think YouTube is
having some issues today the DLC ending is better if you
completed the game before which I have which I have I have
completed the game before.
I have the knowledge in my brain.
Spank and Hive!
Thanks for the time, Givda.
Thank you.
Parts of the ship log will affect elements of the DLC.
Ah-ha!
Ah-ha.
What should I do?
It doesn't matter, don't worry.
Okay.
Maybe it's okay then.
It doesn't matter.
Okay.
Then I'm just going to resume.
And hopefully it's okay.
Hopefully it's okay.
That feels so cool being here again.
So yeah, I kind of, um...
Here, I can even show you...
Like I started the game yesterday.
Oh, I already got them from the Observe.
Oh, see?
See, I literally only did one loop.
Thanks for streaming this.
Thank you for the super chat.
I already got them.
Must be inhaling more fumes than I realized.
That stuff is potent.
Well, if you've got the codes, I'm not going to stop you.
Good luck and take care of that ship.
Let's see.
My poor ship lost.
I went to Giants Deep And that's about all I did I saw I saw
Gabbro I saw the bro That's all Everything else is Look
Everything else is It's totally empty It feels so I was like
no I've done more All you need is the quantum moon and the
center of the interloper.
Oh.
He didn't go to the bramble?
No way!
I would...
No way.
Did you get meditation?
No, I think I needed to have, um, gone through a loop first
to get the meditation.
So maybe, maybe before we do the DLC, um, maybe I will
grab...
Oh wait.
Maybe I will grab a couple things, right?
Okay.
Maybe it would be good.
Core things that make the DLC better that add scenes are
visiting the comet and your teleporting moon friend mainly.
But it's not essential.
Okay.
But I do kind of want like the full experience, right?
Because like I beat the game.
So it's kind of like...
Oh, oh, am I gonna make it?
Ouch.
Oh god.
Nobody saw that.
Oh my goodness, that is so loud.
I might need your help then.
If you guys, backseaters rejoice.
I might need your help then a little bit.
With exactly where I need to go.
If you guys don't mind a little bit.
And if you don't mind a little bit of exploration.
Before we get into the DLC itself.
Finally, it's our time to shine.
Yeah, like it just opened its eyes.
and they're like, whoa, wow, wow, wow, but the DLC is here,
right?
New exhibit.
The radio tower here on Timber Hearth was built to receive
transmissions from our deep space satellite, and to this day
still houses the first ever photos taken of the entire solar
system.
Am I in the way?
These photos were made possible by the deep space
satellites' unusual vertical orbit.
orbit that carries it high above and below the plane of the
solar system oh so it's the radio tower not here thanks to a
recent upgrade the deep space satellite is now responsible
for generating the real-time solar system map used by our
newest astronauts okay hello quantum unusual signal
Creepy.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Um, hello?
Ew!
These fish, these dang stinking fish.
You have your textures on one eighth.
I was worried about my computer.
Maybe I'll change it.
Wait.
Oh, you know, I'll just do full.
I think I changed everything else from very high to high,
though.
Except, yeah, it should be fine then.
Corky.
Thanks for the time gifted.
Thank you.
Absolutely.
Adore this game.
I'll have fun with the DLC.
Thank you, Waffle and Sign.
Thank you.
Waffles.
Hmm.
Can I leave the menu?
I'm going to resume.
That's amazing that you could tell immediately.
You were like, um, your textures are not optimal.
That's so crazy.
The pictures were very crunchy.
Oh, was that why?
Oh, you're right.
I'm like, wow!
How could you tell?
I thought that's just how they were supposed to be.
Okay, I get it.
I was like, wow, I can't see anything.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Wow, it's such a nice day.
To die.
Oh wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I'm dying.
Let's go back to our ship and let's go get some of the
things that we need for an optimal ending.
So happy to see you again, Mintao.
Thank you.
More, oh, oh, oh, wait, I'm gonna die here.
Whoopsie.
I forgot that.
I'm going to turn the audio down just a little bit because
it's quite loud.
Oh, whoopsie.
Whoa, that's fine.
We have the full day now, right?
We have the full day.
It's all good.
Whoopsie!
Okay.
So you guys said the meteor, the interloper?
Oh gosh, how do I get there again?
Hmm.
It wasn't just crash landing on it, right?
Or just fly onto it?
Interloper and quantum moon.
How do I get to the quantum moon again?
Do you remember how to get to the quantum moon?
I can just fly to the interloper.
Okay, let's fly there then.
Let's not fly into the sun.
Where's the sun?
Over there.
Okay, we're good.
Okay.
All right.
Where's our interloper, friend?
Somewhere.
Giant state.
Is that the moon right there?
Oh gosh, what was it again?
I'll remember eventually.
Wait, oh hold on, hold on, hold on.
Did it have to do with...
With the camera, right?
Is that it?
No, that's somewhat...
What is that?
Why is Left Stick not doing anything?
Hmm.
Is that the...
The White Hole Moon or the Station?
White Hole Station?
Yes, yes?
Jeffrey!
Are you actually here?
Jeffrey, I had to make a new game, so I'm getting some of
the stuff...
Wait!
Nope, that's just a really bright star.
Where the heck is this thing?
Hello?
Interloper.
Go into your settings and rebind.
Maybe I have to.
Controls.
Oh, wait.
Movement?
Oh, just kidding.
Righty.
Should be fine, right?
Wait.
Uh.
Flight.
Lock on.
Yeah, I've been pressing down on LS.
Hmm, weird.
Ducky, thanks for the gift, Dad.
Mm-hmm.
Jeffrey said known bug.
I'm getting a sense of deja vu.
I don't know about you.
Okay, hold on.
How do I unbind it?
Oh.
Wait.
Okay.
I'm sorry, the lock-on bug has haunted me for years.
Just rewind lock-on again.
Okay, thank you, Jeffrey.
I'm playing this because I saw that you were able to...
Or I heard, rather, that you were able to meet Matara,
Offkay.
Unless she's a liar.
But I got your note.
Thank you.
the 10 gifted where the heck is okay let's see if it works
now oh yippee okay i'm looking for the interloper i'm
looking for the interloper wait is that the no that's ash
twin i was like is that the sun station i wonder wait
where'd the quantum moon go wait i see it I see it!
I'm gonna miss it.
It's gonna go straight to the side.
Wait, uh, hold on.
Uh, interloper!
I see you!
Yes!
Use your map.
It's more fun to use my eyes a little bit, right?
Oh gosh.
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to reach this.
Casey, thanks for the vibe gifter!
Thank you.
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
Okay.
We might be fine.
Maybe.
Coming in hot.
How do I...
I don't remember how to...
Okay.
I'm coming in real hot.
Oh, great.
Um.
Here I am.
Interloper.
Oh, my goodness.
I don't know.
How do I land again?
I don't remember.
Ah!
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's good.
Bunk.
Oh, shoot.
No!
I don't want to die!
Wait!
Ah!
Oh, let's hear it.
I'm here!
I'm
here!
Oh, wait.
No, no, no, please.
Interloper.
Let me on you.
Okay, I'm falling.
I'm in the gravity source.
gravitational pull wait how do i go down here we go no
please please it's been a minute since i've played this game
cinder oh no i'm gonna reach this way wait wait wait oh god
please let me let me on you okay oh it's fine just a scratch
all right we're here just don't jump just don't jump Little
alien.
Where'd they, uh...
Here, here, here, here.
Oh, ouch.
Ouch.
Oh.
Uh, uh, okay.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
This is a thing I need, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Um...
The shuttle may freeze entirely.
I got my Mintera postcard today!
I think it got caught in a conveyor.
Oh, no!
Really?
Avi!
Thanks for the...
50?
Oh, wait, hold on.
Sorry, if I click out of the...
Thank you for the 50 gift.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, next page.
Sorry, I'm going to skip some...
Actually, no.
I'm not going to skip through it because I want a good
recap, right?
Even if it did, couldn't someone call it back home to the
gravity cannon on Ember Twin?
Takes quite the specimen to nearly miss falling on the
ground.
Stop.
Yes, but the exploration of the comet would be more
difficult if we were without the shuttle until someone
recalled it.
Perhaps we shouldn't have landed on the dark side of the
comet.
Suppose one of us remained in the shuttle to keep it warm
and continue monitoring the surface.
This would be wise, I think, Clary.
If you don't mind waiting here with it, Pokey and I can
continue to investigate the surface.
So, from my memory, from my memory, the comet is basically
the cause of, like, their overall demise right there was
like the had like the stuff inside oh sorry spoilers if you
have not played please don't watch the stream the ghost
matter the ghost matter yes so basically i remember going
into the comet and just seeing them dead in there and it's
so sad okay ship log updated?
Can we get inside there?
Was there a way to or maybe there wasn't?
Can I get inside?
Oh, how do I get inside the comet now?
Go in there again for the log?
Yeah, yeah, I just have to figure out how to get in it.
When it's near the sun, it's got to melt, right?
Oh, no!
Wait!
It already passed!
Oh, shoot.
Why did you Spread your matter all over the solar system.
It's just, you know, ghosty things, right?
Where's my ship?
Oh, no!
Well, it won't go back to the sun, right?
I think we won't have the chance to.
Um...
Hmm.
Well, shoot.
I have to be really fast, then, don't I?
Ugh.
That's okay.
We have one more pass, but not for a while.
Well, I'm here, so...
I might run out of oxygen, though.
Where'd my ship go?
Oh.
Maybe I can reach my ship.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Ship!
Um...
I don't want to...
Oh, gosh.
The bramble.
Ship!
Ship, ship, ship.
Oh my god, it's so close.
I'm just gonna jump for it.
You guys, I'm gonna jump for it.
I'm coming for you!
Ship?
It's in, like, the gravitational pole, so... Wait, can I
actually match its velocity?
Come on, ship.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I might have enough fuel.
I might be able to do this.
Wait, I might be able to do this.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
I can do this.
Ship.
Where's the entrance?
Come on, ship.
Where are you?
Oh, there it is.
I see you.
I see it, I see it, I see it.
I see it.
I can do
this.
Yes!
Yippee!
Um, anyway, uh, buckle up buttercup or where else did I
need- oh, the quantum moon.
So cool just being here though.
Are we that- are we so close to the sun?
Um, how do I view my map?
Oh.
No.
Oh, it's gonna take a while, isn't it?
The moon, or the sun's getting pretty red.
Nice flying ace.
Thank you.
Um.
Oh, yeah.
We're like, oh, we're like about, oh, we're halfway there.
Whoa.
Hmm.
You are in orbit.
Should we try again since we're here?
Squibbord on a chair!
I feel like it won't be so long.
I feel like if I go back...
I might be able to do it.
I'm in orbit with the thing now, so...
Hmm...
Is she doing the DLC?
Yes!
I might honestly give up if things are so...
If it takes too long, if I'm so bad at it, I might give up.
I'll be honest.
But I don't want to give up.
Can I get you in there?
Can I just scoot you in real close?
Yeah, there we go.
Nice!
Good la- Ooh, snowflake.
Good landing.
Wait, how far a map?
okay i'll wait till we're a little bit closer probably oh
get the meditate tool okay i'll get the meditate too we'll
have to go back to giant's deep then you can do it thank you
look it's staying wait uh where do i need is is around here
good to stay don't you go now what oh i see you Let's say no
initial D.
The other end.
Other side.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Thank you, guys, for directing me.
Oh, where the red, where the red is.
Okay, okay.
For anybody coming in being like, hey, this isn't the DLC.
Um, that's because...
I had to start a new game and um okay I think we're close
right maybe not close enough oh I might die I had to start a
new game but to get like the best ending of uh I passed it
oh you know where it's at look for the cracks in the rocky
area Okay.
Cracks in the rocky area.
Oh, it's starting to melt!
Oh no!
Uh-oh.
Here?
Here.
We made it!
Uh-oh, gosh.
Wait, how...
Uh, okay.
Uh...
Oh, no, this is where Ghost Matter is.
Uh, that looks like kind of Ghost Matter-y, I'm just saying.
Oh no!
Not me.
And take a snapshot.
Yep, okay.
Uh, this way.
Okay, uh...
Oh, log, log, log.
Log, log, log.
Okay.
I'm receiving much stronger energy readings now that we're
beneath the crust.
Whatever it is must lie somewhere below, closer to the
comet's center.
it's more dangerous than we realized.
Clary, can you hear us?
Bye-bye, ship.
It's okay, we're gonna die here anyway.
Yes, but your voices are faint.
I fear we will lose communication entirely if you continue
any deeper.
Keep the shuttle warm for us, Clary.
We'll return the moment we identify the source of the energy
readings.
I understand, but be cautious, both of you.
Oh.
Oxygen!
Hooray!
Okay, um...
Oops, uh...
Where's the ghost matter at?
Oh, me!
So I can go down this one, right?
The ghost matter...
Yeah, we can go down this one, right?
It's a winner.
Safe.
Let's go, baby.
But be careful.
Don't go too fast.
Avoid the ghost matter!
How do I...
How do I turn my flash?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Nice.
Now I think we have to go...
Oh!
Above?
Up and beyond?
I think?
Mmm.
Up?
I'm too scared.
We can't go down the...
Yeah, that's all ghost matter.
Oh, where...
It's so hard to tell.
It's so hard to tell sometimes.
Maybe I should keep him up there.
That's the Ghost Matter hole.
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
I...
You would think that a ghost like myself would be...
Look, it even looks like me, doesn't it?
So funny.
Okay, how do I get...
I'm scared.
What if I fall into the hole?
the hole and die okay good job team any ghost matter around
these parts me no matter every hole is a goal ah where's the
ghost matter me hidden matter See ya!
Oh.
Oh!
I don't think I can go down there.
This way?
Or is this where I just came from?
Oh gosh.
Wait, this looks...
This appears...
Yeah, this is where I just came from.
You have to choose the right path.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, scary, scary, scary, scary.
Okay, so I have to go right, left.
Okay, right, left.
I can't tell.
There's ghost matter in the bottom right-hand corner of the
screen.
Ow!
There's the one, there, whoa, we're so close to the center.
We might want to use camera view for this.
Oh, how do I do that again?
This one?
Launch mode?
Or?
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, we're going to have to take this nice and easy,
everybody.
Nice and easy.
But it was left first, right?
Oh, gosh.
No, just kidding.
That's too fast!
I'm too fast!
Okay.
Now.
We're fine.
Keep going.
Slow and steady.
Any ghosts matter.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
Where?
Ah!
Oh,
dead body!
Um, we did it.
Okay.
Is this a hole?
Uh...
Yes, I do believe so.
Okay.
See.
Whoa.
I've played this before and even still I'm just like, wow!
Oh!
We can take it back.
Uh-oh.
Grab you?
Oh no!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Stop, stop, stop, stop!
I'm trying to read it!
Hold on!
The spherical casing here seems to be the source of the
energy readings.
Can I please...
Take you back!
Okay.
There we go.
I'm so sorry.
I love physics.
Okay.
Guys, this is an emotional area, okay?
Wasn't there a button to stop time while reading?
That's what this is now, so.
The spherical stone casing here seems to be the source of
the energy readings.
No, rather the source of what's within the stone.
I'm detecting some form of exotic matter.
The stone is muting our energy readings.
They should be ten times what we're seeing, at least.
Ugh.
pie I don't think we want this matter interacting with us as
far as I can tell direct contact with it would almost
certainly be fatal I've never encountered anything like this
casing it's all but it's all that's protecting us from
what's inside we're still this matter is disturbingly
volatile pie whatever the matter inside this stone casing is
it's more than just profoundly unstable it's under tons of
pressure.
Look at this density scan.
I've never seen anything this tightly compacted before.
What is this?
Why are you guys sending tongues, huh?
Oh, because I bit my tongue.
This is orders of magnitude worse than I'd imagine.
If this stone were to rupture, the lethal matter within
would rapidly expand, completely blanketing this star system
almost instantaneously.
And the pressure is still building The comet approaches the
star system.
Return to the shuttle right now.
The rest of our friends need to know that they're in
terrible danger.
Leave your equipment and run.
What are you doing, Pai?
The more we know about this alien matter, the better our
chances of survival.
Survival!
I can't speak.
Sounds like it's about to bust.
But this thing's busted, man.
I will learn what I can here.
Go warn the others.
Maybe they can construct shelter somehow.
Now, Pokey.
All right, so we got this information.
I'm upside down.
Did I get everything in here, I think?
Can I hit my...
Dang it, I missed.
Sorry.
Interloper.
Oh, I hardly know her.
Where did I come from?
Through that hole, I think?
Yeah.
It's so beautiful, though.
Oh, Ghost Matter.
Look at you.
Wait.
Wait, there's a second hole.
This is a different hole.
Oh, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
That hole up there is a different hole.
Oh, that's probably a bad hole.
Ghost Matter hole.
Um, but I am going to die here anyway, so...
We're beautiful and mysterious.
Dang.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, that hole is full of me!
Hazard, hazard!
Oh no!
Oh no, are you okay?
Um, I guess we'll just wait it out until we...
Until 60 seconds left, everybody.
Oh, we're by the sun again.
Never mind.
I didn't think that it went into the sun.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
The quantum moon, though, I imagine, is going to have a lot
of stuff that...
You know what I mean?
Because there's, like, all the different...
Like, there's the...
Bramble moon, and there's, like, the...
There's a lot of stuff...
Wait, I have to go back to the Frozen No-Mai shuttle?
Or did I get everything that will be needed for the DLC?
But you already have the knowledge.
Yeah, but apparently if you have it in your logs, then
there's a slightly different outcome of the game.
You got everything needed?
Okay, cool.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Got what you needed from the interloper.
Awesome.
Um...
It's enough knowledge for that part.
Thanks, Jeffrey!
Sucks that I had to do a whole new game.
Then I'm wasting a little bit of time.
But that's okay because I just enjoy going around so much in
this.
So let's go find ourselves a quantum moon!
So don't go to the sun.
If I were a quantum moon...
That's not it.
No, that's idle rock.
If I were a quantum moon, I'd be right there.
A little recap.
Yeah, this is good, though.
Okay, so with this...
I have to take a picture of you.
Don't go into him.
Don't fly in.
Don't touch.
Okay.
Wait, how do I...
Um...
Unbuckle.
Photo mode.
Say cheese!
Cheese!
Okay, now I can buckle back- Wait.
Whoopsie!
Let's check our map.
If I were a Quantum Moon, where would I be if I were a
Quantum Moon?
Oh, wait.
I just saw that other rotation.
It looks like for the DLC.
Wait.
Is that...
No, that's the Hourglass Twins.
Will it show up on here?
Ah!
No!
Why are you at the Bramble?
Well, it might have moved by now, actually.
Where is the Bramble?
Can I look at my map from here?
Okay.
You know what?
Good.
It left the Bramble.
Where are you now?
The Bramble.
Are you a giant sheep?
No.
If I were...
Where are...
Where are you?
Am I blind?
It will keep moving.
You gotta find it on...
Oh!
Will it... If I lock on...
Will it keep...
I think I have to go actually look for it.
Ah!
Oh!
I found it.
Stop doubting my abilities.
Okay, so I can't go in with my ship.
I'm really close to the sun, though.
I'm kind of scared.
I'm real close to the...
I'm real close to the sun.
You got...
Oh, I'm glad that doesn't count as...
Okay, photo mode.
Take a snapshot.
Why?
Where are you going?
You can enter.
on your ship.
Wait, how do I...
Okay, you guys might need to backseat me a little bit more
because I'm, I'm confusion.
Your ship has a camera.
It does!
There it goes.
Launch the ship.
Okay, okay.
Well, it's gone now.
So, um, let's figure out where it went this time.
We got this.
So, I launched the scouter on my ship and then it should be
good.
there perfect perfect okay
it's the exact same control as a scout launcher okay thank
you guys sorry it's been a minute it's been a minute okay i
appreciate you being patient with me this is good too though
because i'll remember how to do stuff for the dlc too so now
Did that take a picture?
I think that's it.
And they're right.
So, is that it?
Now I'm good.
So now I can go in.
Here we go.
Here I go.
Full speed!
AAAAAAAAHHHHH!
Whoa.
Okay, now I have to remember.
So I said some...
Don't do certain things here, right?
They were like, don't go to certain areas.
Whoa, so scary.
Uh, wait, it's Y, right?
Do not jump.
Where do you think you're?
going.
I have to find that one building.
Go north?
This, this away.
The ship's fine, everybody.
The ship's fine.
Quantum ship.
Uh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Hello.
Wait, we're fine.
Find the tower, yeah.
Oh, there!
Is that it?
Nope, that's just a really thick tree.
Yeah, I'm looking for the tower now.
Because I know that's where we have to go.
Did I, like, land in the worst possible place?
Is that even possible?
It's so scary here.
I'm so excited for the DLC.
Oh!
There it is.
Perfect.
Now, one thing I don't remember...
One thing I don't remember... Oh, I have to be in this spot,
right?
Has to be in the secret spot?
Yep, okay, cool.
Oh, let's grab this stuff too, just in case.
Okay.
Very nice.
Alright, we turn off the lights.
And we are, uh, not there.
Can I turn on my flashlight?
Not there.
There!
This looks complicated.
Oh.
The shrine has to be at the North Pole.
Oh, shoot.
How do I...
I assure that.
You have to be at the North Pole first.
Oh, no.
Wait, so I have to go to the North Pole?
North Pole before teleporting there.
Oh, you have to leave the tower in different planets.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Stop it.
Let's try here.
Wait, I'm scared.
Isn't this the Bramble World?
Eee-ee-ee-ee!
Oh, yes, because we can't always get to the North Pole.
But we can hear, perhaps, maybe.
Okay.
Scary, scary, scary.
Hope there's no fishing room.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's all coming back to me slowly but surely.
Slowly but surely.
Actually, does this work?
I don't think it does.
I don't think this...
I don't think this does work.
We're not entirely at the North Pole.
We're, like, mostly at the North Pole.
Made it further.
Oh, I don't know why I always turn the lights on.
I have my flashlight.
Okay.
Maybe here?
Does not...
Wait.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Oh, wait.
Not quite.
Wait, I got it?
What do you mean I got it?
Oh, this works, for real?
Oh, hello.
Oh, oh, goodbye.
Just spin?
Oh, okay, cool.
I'm spinning, I'm spinning.
Spinning all around.
Oh!
Yippee!
Okay.
Thanks, guys, for your help.
Really, truly appreciate you guys.
Thank you.
Oh, first try, baby.
Oh, we're here.
And, uh, we gotta go talk to somebody.
Okay.
Speed run.
For real, right?
This game is so spooky.
Hits every good beat.
Am I going the wrong way?
Oh, wait.
Do I go into the hole?
Oh, I can't remember.
You're going right?
Wait, I go into the hole and...
Wait.
into the hole okay not yet where where is she not yet okay
is she close to the hole ah found her found her found her
whoa how are you
oh that's right okay this is a lot okay I remember all this
there's like so many things that we're gonna have to like
mix and match and talk to about do you guys mind if i um i
don't want to skip through it but
where do i put it oh thank you
we've heard it before it's okay
it's so cool though it's so awesome Have you encountered a
quantum shard on another planet?
The shards look the same as the quantum moon's surface does
now, while at the eye.
From this, we can reasonably infer the quantum moon's
natural state is as we see it now, and that the eye is its
primary location.
Okay, I am gonna skip a little bit through it.
Ship log updated.
Okay, we updated one thing.
We're like, it's so funny, I've done nothing, but we're in
endgame.
game.
Okay, find the eye.
I'm just unsure how you arrived here.
Yes, yes, yes.
Very good.
Speed lore.
Fundamental uncertainty throughout the universe.
The eye.
Oh my gosh.
Can't wait to do more about the eye.
Quantum moon probably exhibits macroscopic quantum behavior
because of its proximity to the eye.
Blah, blah, blah.
And then your clan died.
So sad.
But it's not from the eye.
It's from the ghost matter.
I am on my first pilgrimage to the quantum moon.
All know Maya and my clan make this journey when we come of
age.
That's because so crazy.
I would be so scared.
Okay.
we switch it out.
From explanation to identify stone.
Okie dokie.
Identify me.
Solanumbus, girl.
I've never met one of your kind before.
It's an honor to speak with you.
I particularly admire your four eyes.
You call me a nerd!
Hey there, four eyes.
I would there's so there are many questions I would ask if I
could comprehend your language you have my gratitude for
understanding mine what if I didn't understand it what if I
just was like yeah stop using that emote this is the quantum
moon we are both where we are both standing despite also
orbiting other celestial bodies the quantum moon is the eye
of the universe's moon oh my brain much this like this game
makes my brain go hope i am sullen him and no my my clan
arrived in this star system before my birth and we now call
it home cute yes they were searching for the eye and they
ended up in the bramble right and then they all went to like
the different planets and kind of set up base there but then
the the interloper caused them to all die right
Why you don't have a nerd emo?
What are you talking about?
My otaku...
Oh, otaku.
My otaku emo is the nerd emo.
Sorry, I'm eating my dinner.
You can make stones of the same color.
You can?
We are orbiting the eye of the universe now.
Although we cannot see it.
Only the quantum moon's reflection of it.
the eye is older than the universe itself and my clan
believes it dwells in an extremely distant orbit around the
solar system oh oh
taco I suppose suppose you could reach the eye of the
universe would you try to enter it what do you imagine the
effects of a conscious observer might be freaky so freaky
Hey Mint, hello!
Imagine you've noticed the quantum moon changes in
appearance depending on which location it is currently
orbiting.
For instance, yes.
So we knew that, but because the quantum moon clearly
changes in its different forms, the eye, being this moon's
primary location, must be similarly malleable.
From this, we can hypothesize that the eye represents
extreme changeability.
That said, despite its malleable nature, the quantum moon
becomes locked to one specific version of itself when it is
consciously.
observed.
But what would happen if a conscious observer were to enter
the eye?
Wait, which ones have I been switching out?
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
I don't... This one, right?
This one, right?
I think so.
Okay.
Give me more text.
Speak.
Speak you.
Okay.
Like many of the clan before me, I journeyed here to see the
quantum moon's reflection of the eye.
This is the closest any of us have come to seeing the eye
itself.
You may think I'm strange, but I have a hypothesis that I
may not be entirely alive.
Perhaps my journey has reached its end.
Oh, shiplock.
Okay, good, good, good, good, good.
Say I don't sproy it.
Oh, I swapped the other one?
Oh.
It's okay.
Because, uh...
I'm just gonna get all of them because I don't know what we
need and what we do.
don't need.
Kao!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Is this your first time on the Quantum Moon?
It's my first time here.
If you've come here looking for answers, I hope you find
them.
Oof.
I'm left with so many questions.
Did I do this one?
I like dropping them on the floor to keep track.
That's a good idea.
Okay.
We'll put that there then.
But it looks so pretty up on there, right?
the wall instead.
Okay, we've gotten this one.
We probably haven't done this one and this one, right?
You.
You!
Many of my clan have believed that I called to us for a
particular purpose.
When I was a child, they used to believe that I was
malevolent.
To have lured my clan to the star system, only to them
vanish from them so completely.
But I don't fear the I anymore.
In fact, it became my fondest hope to see the eye itself.
Someday.
But I fear this may be beyond my reach.
You may think I'm strange.
But I have a hypothesis that I may not...
Oh, okay, yes.
Maybe I got all of them now.
Just kidding.
We do not have much connection, you and I.
Still, this encounter feels special.
I hope you won't mind if I think of you as a friend.
Oh, my friend.
An hypothesis.
Okay.
I think we got everything, though.
Yes.
Oh, my brain is hurting.
From which ones I've put up here and which ones I haven't.
It's my birthday.
Chaotic's still happy birthday.
Yay.
happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear chaotic snow happy birthday to you happy birthday okay
now I think we've gotten all of them
I do these two.
Oh my gosh, wait, it worked.
These are the two tenets of Nomai philosophy.
To seek out and to understand is our way of living.
Oh.
Okay.
Nerds.
I think that's actually...
I can't.
I'm too paranoid.
Okay.
Let's do it all over again, I suppose.
I think you got it with the last log up there.
Okay.
I'm just doing one last check.
You can fly into the eyeshadow to find the quantum shuttle
if you want.
There's an additional scene if you can visit.
If you can get to...
Wait, can get if you visit the ship mural in Brittle Hollow.
Oh, okay.
Last thing to do is visit the mural on the vessel in the
black hole planet, or visit the vessel in Bramble.
You should totally visit Bramble.
Wait, is it Brittle Hollow or Bramble?
Wait, vessel in the black hole planet.
Oh, either one?
Brittle Bramble?
Vessel is in the Bramble.
You just need to know what happened to the vessel.
Both works, but the vessel takes longer.
Brittle Hollow is easier.
Wait, I don't quite remember where it is.
I think I've got all of these, so...
Now, let's not make a mess.
Let's clean up our...
Nice.
Let's clean up our mess.
Made in action.
It's in my DNA!
If I even have that anymore.
Go to the mural on the vessel at the black hole inside of
the bramble.
I think it's time.
Wait!
Solanum!
No!
You have to!
You can escape with me!
Come on!
Just hop on my ship!
Wah!
Thank you for the!
Ah, guys!
Oh, this is a red.
Has the sun...
Wait, what was it?
There's a special ending here?
Really?
Oh my gosh.
Hug it out.
Weeeeee.
So close.
So cute.
You're so close.
Oh.
Um, hold on.
I'm gonna get a picture of the two of us.
Wait, launch it.
Launch it.
Oh, launch it.
Yeah!
Let's get it closer, get a little closer.
Yay!
Give me one second, I'll read your Aqua Supa in just a
second.
Aww, friends.
Just the two of us.
We can make it if we try.
You and I.
Our last memory.
So cute.
Lots of...
Lots of quantum stuff.
I did talk to Galbro.
have to go talk to him again thank you for reminding me yes
because i was recommended to get the give me one second i
was recommended to get the meditate as is the sun you hear
that music the end times have come why is it so sad thank
you so much uh scathely thank you for that question but
thank you okay all righty yeah we gotta go talk to garbo No,
his name is Gab, bro.
Okay.
So, I should go talk to him.
And I should go...
To...
Wait.
Bramble or Brittle Hollow?
I don't want to go to...
I'm scared of Brittle Hollow.
Where is...
Where are we going?
Quanta Moon.
Brittle Hollow is easier?
Where are you?
There you are.
Giant Steep is kind of a pain in the butt to get around,
though.
Because it's so gravity heavy.
I think you can do brittle and gabbro in the same loop.
That's what I'm gonna try.
I'm gonna...
There will be an attempt.
Alright.
Go on in, baby!
Okay.
Oh, learning...
Ow!
Okay.
It ends the loop if I learn the meditation.
Uh-oh.
Where is he?
Oh my goodness.
I hope he wasn't there.
Because he sure is gone now.
Ah, there he is.
Oh, whoops.
Ah, it's fine.
As long as I can get out.
Unbuckle.
Nice.
Ouch!
Oh, there he is.
All good, everybody.
I was hoping you'd be back.
Something really weird is going on.
You think we're in a time loop?
Oh, we're definitely in a time loop.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Cool.
What do you think it was?
I figured it'd be some kind of fidgety time business, but I
wasn't really thinking about what's happening to the shape
of time, you know.
But a loop makes sense here.
Let's go with loop for now.
So it looks like you and I are the only ones Who know we're
in a time loop And even if you tell them about it No one
remembers by the next loop Let's put that Maybe it's because
we both made some seriously Intense eye contact with a Nomai
statue Yeah, yeah, yeah Um I found something Uh My time
buddy's back Wait
Oh I have to come back on the next loop Okay.
You have to unlock a visit him twice.
Dang.
That's okay.
Let's fix the ship.
Oh.
And then we'll head over.
Oh, can I even get up there?
Uh-oh.
Let's wait until we go into outer space.
Okay.
uh we might be going into outer space like right now
beam me up scottie
right here right now here we go okay go go go go go go go go
go go go go go wait wait wait oh god oh god No, no, no, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
I'm a genius, I'm a genius.
I'm a genius, everybody.
Okay, buckle up.
And let's leave.
Perfect.
Perfect execution.
We only have a few cracks on our screen.
Okay, not there.
Uh-oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Coming in a little bit hot there, baby.
There it is.
I have no idea where to go, though.
Truthfully, I have no idea where to go for this mural.
Did you drop your phone?
Nice crosshair.
It's near the drop.
Look for the escape pod.
Look for the beacon.
near the escape pod.
I don't remember where that is.
Emergency beacon.
Okay, I'm looking for a beacon.
Use a signal scope.
Okay, to locate the emergency beacon.
Thank you.
That's what we shall try to do.
Unless it's...
No, that's the launcher right there.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We came in hot, hot.
Oh, dang.
Yep, there we go.
Nice!
That was probably the best landing I think I've ever done in
my career.
That was probably the absolute best landing I've ever done
ever.
That's pretty impressive, I would say.
Nice.
Okay, let's not die.
All right, signal scope.
That's not it.
But that's all.
No.
Change the frequency?
That?
Might be good to go visit our banjo friend though for some
oxygen.
Oh that's...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, that's the quantum rock?
What does it sound like instead?
Museum shard.
What?
Oh my goodness.
Why am I so bad at this?
What?
Why am I so...
Uh...
Change the frequency.
Oh no, I don't think I have it!
Oh no, I don't think I have the frequency!
Uh oh.
Oh shoot.
We're just gonna...
Go around and...
Oh wait, we can get some...
We can get some oxygen here.
And some fuel and stuff.
That'll be good.
Guess we zoom.
We just gotta find the mural, right?
We just gotta get to the mural.
Where is your oxygen?
Oh, ouch.
I didn't mean to go down so hard.
Or your fuel, I mean.
I think I keep saying oxygen.
What the heck is that?
Space egg.
Ghost matter.
Where's your fuel?
Is there none here?
Okay.
Let's just keep moving then.
Oh.
Okay, I'm gonna go along the equator.
I think we can do it.
If not, um, that's okay, too.
Okay.
Boom, boom, boom.
This is the cannon.
So actually my ship is probably faster.
Yeah, but did you see that landing?
It's fine.
It didn't take us that long to get to Gabro and you know
we're getting more oxygen.
It's all good, baby.
But after this, I will...
Well, I gotta get the Meditate, and then we'll do the DLC.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Maybe I should have just played on my other account.
Wait, is that it?
Do I see it with my...
Eyes!
I believe!
But this has been a great way to kind of reintroduce myself
back to the...
Back to the game.
Okay, so down here, right?
Uh-oh.
I don't know how much fuel.
Follow the platforms below.
How do I get to the platform?
Which is a great question.
I know these drop.
Like, some of them break down, you know?
So I'm kind of nervous to just drop down.
Please don't break.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh.
Made it.
Okay.
This way.
Let's keep going.
Where do I go from here?
Miro should be the lower section of here.
like
oh gosh i don't want to go i don't i don't want to go into
the to the black hole down here maybe
everybody backseeding thank you maybe i shouldn't even say
backseeding you're just helping drop below here okay oh no
oh no i can't make it in oh gosh uh
sideways.
So I have to go in here.
Oh, I see it.
Oh, shoot.
I'm gonna grab this too, just so guys.
How do I get down there?
You can just walk around, I can.
Like, so?
If I drop down here, will I make it?
Or...
Ooh.
Okay.
Risking it for the biscuit.
I guess.
Ouch!
We're fine!
Oh, nice!
Why did the vessel crash in that place?
Was the vessel unwell?
Probably not the vessel, but the destination.
I'm afraid for our friends and escape pod 3.
And yippee!
we get all these two.
Okay, good, good, good.
All right.
Vessel looks for I.
Vessel trapped in Bramble.
Escape from Bramble to other planets.
Nice little summary.
Okay.
DLC starto.
Lord get.
Yay!
Thank you guys.
Thank you for your patience.
Thank you for helping me out.
Um, we're gonna do one more.
Look at my ship.
I love this view.
Tori, welcome to Mambu's ship there.
Cool.
We're going to do one last loop because we're going to get
Meditate and then we shall go for the DLC.
Thank you for the summary, boss.
Of course.
Don't thank me.
I'm just going to die in space.
We'll have no fuel.
How close can I get to the sun?
openly discussing a backseat in the game like this for a bit
has been an unusual experience but also fun it is weird for
me too because usually i'd be like no no no don't tell me
anything but it's all stuff that i've experienced before so
it's just kind of like whatever you know it's just kind of
whatever um just it's just uh the it's just getting it so
that we can um Proceed forward.
You will hit the sun before you run out of oxygen.
Will we, though?
I'm almost out of fuel.
But maybe I have enough...
Oh.
Okay.
Maybe I have enough momentum to launch me.
Into the sun!
Here we go.
Everybody shield your eyes.
Oh, it's so bright.
I'm touching grass.
Yes!
Nice.
Okay.
To you.
All right, don't go anywhere.
Don't go anywhere.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Stay with me!
Gonna go grab that meditate.
It's so crazy how you could literally just speed run this
game.
If you just know where to go.
If you know the secret of the quantum moon, you can be like,
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
Hey, quantum moon.
Hi, quantum moon.
Current record is like six minutes.
That's crazy.
Wow.
Oh, there he is.
Perfect.
Land.
Oh, not in the trees again.
Come on.
Don't do this to me.
Okay.
Perfect.
Great landing!
Give me the meditate, man.
They also run it shipless?
Is that even possible?
How do you get out of...
How do you get off of Timberhurst?
My time, buddy.
Um...
How do you stay so calm in the face of repeating and ending
death?
Deep breaths.
Seriously, I meditate.
Want me to teach you?
Sure.
Close your eyes.
Ah, here we go.
Here we go.
Physics?
Wait until you find out about Suitless.
What?
That doesn't seem possible!
Oh my god, an hour and 30 minutes into the stream.
And we're finally getting to the DLC, baby.
Okay, let's go find that radio tower.
I'm just gonna use the spaceship.
Hmm.
Oh!
I'm just using the spaceship.
There's a geyser.
Why is this planet so flat?
Besides like some mountains and...
Let's see.
I have such a delicate touch, don't I?
Being able to fly so...
Easy.
Oh, wait.
Is this it?
No.
This is...
What's up there?
It's a tree boss?
Oh, okay.
Her...
What are you saying?
What?
What does that mean?
Okay, I think I remember this forest.
It has like, there's like the one forest where the trees are
also kind of quantum-y.
If I were a radio tower, you'd think it would be way easier
to see.
Maybe I should go into space a little bit more.
Wait.
Aha!
I'm sideways.
Good landing.
No panic at all.
The quantum grove, yeah.
Yeah, it's pretty freaky in there.
Hello, hello.
Oh, I've seen that before.
I've seen that before.
Oh!
And we're recording.
Ahem.
It's been two days since the launch of the Deep Space
Satellite, and I'm about to view the first batch of photos.
Look at that.
The record show that on this historic day, Outer Wilds
Ventures has...
Ah!
They're printing!
Here they come!
Stars above, will you?
Look at that.
There's Brittle Hollow.
And look, look there.
That's Hollow's Lantern.
And there's Giants Deep.
And...
And the Quantum Moon!
I'm speechless.
speechless every single astral body wait if we had a picture
of quantum moon this whole time why is it still moving
around every single astral body in our magnificent solar
system looking stunning from from every angle in each of
these three images because nobody was looking at the picture
oh I guess that's fair and in color no less now this is art
I could stare at these photos forever.
Doesn't Timberhurst look tiny from?
Hold on.
What is that?
That can't be right.
That's, I mean, that's not even possible.
Am I interrupting this, oh, interpreting this photo
correctly?
What's even stranger is, it doesn't show up in either of the
other photos.
Just this one.
Well, there must have been an equipment malfunction, I
suppose.
Only sensible explanation for it.
I'll radio Gabro and ask them to go examine.
the satellite's lens for defects.
Oh god, are you scared me again?
Wait, something that doesn't show up?
That only shows up in one of them.
Only, something that only shows up in one of them.
Besides Gabro.
That's Timberhurth.
No, that's Timberhurth.
Wait, no, yeah, that's Brittle Hollow.
That's Timberhurth.
Huh?
I heard there's a secret scene if you go bramble and touch
fish.
I'm not fish.
It is true.
Sorry for competing.
You're okay.
It only shows up in one of the...
Okay, so we've...
Okay, our first puzzle, everybody.
Woohoo!
Is it that?
Little dot?
Yeah, it's not...
Is it...
And that's Timberhurth, so...
That tiny little dovet?
That's your crosshair?
No!
I wish I could observe it more closely.
There's the...
Yeah, because there's the quantum moon.
And it's not here.
Because this is Timber Hearth.
And that's our...
That's Adel Rock.
And that's us.
Adel Rock.
It's the only thing that I can see different.
Where's my ship?
Uh oh.
Oh there it is.
Okay.
I'm gonna put on my suit.
And see if anything changes when I put it on.
Okay.
rapidly white dot yeah totally okay I see you guys smiling
no spoilers no hints no nothing
20 meters deep space radio oh neat
what is that dang
Is it a quantum thing, so I have to take a picture and
observe it?
Oh, why is it so dark there?
There's quantum moon.
Oh my gosh.
That's Adel Rock.
That's brittle.
That's...
I like quantum moon.
It's always so fun to say hello to the quantum moon.
I don't know why.
Wait, so...
Gabriel will always be spoopy.
It's true.
It's gotta be that, right?
Because it's the only thing that seems different in all
these photos.
Just that tiny... I wish I could like zoom in.
Come on, scoot down.
What is that thing?
It looks kind of like a jellyfish.
I don't say it there.
I know this solar system like the back of my hand.
I've never seen a third thing circulating our planet.
And...
Wait, it's not the quantum moon either.
Even though I don't see where the quantum moon is here.
Push a zoom button.
There's a zoom button.
Zoom?
Zoom.
Oh, the signal scope.
It's so pixel-y!
It's just a little...
It's just a little dot.
It looks like dirt.
Are you sure you know it, like, the back of your hand?
I think so.
Right?
Deep space.
Radio.
Is there any other deep space frequencies that I should be
aware of?
Oh.
Quantum fluctuations.
Hello, quantum moon.
You're listening to deep space radio.
Does the angle matter?
48.
Okay, I'm going to take another picture of it.
Maybe I must launch into space to find such mysterious thing
around us.
I can whistle pretty well, can I?
I think I just learned that about myself.
If you ever need another whistler, Jeffrey, I'm your ghost.
Wait, if I buckle up, I'm gonna lose the picture.
I was like, what's that flashing?
Hmm.
You're pretty good.
Hello!
Where are you at?
This mysterious other presence.
What could you be?
Where are you at?
My eyes.
Oh my god.
I like watching the media go backwards.
Oh, it's so funny.
Sun's looking angry.
No, we still have time.
If I just follow Addle Rock, will I eventually...
That's what it's called, right?
I'm not just saying names, am I?
Hmm.
What if I go to the observatory?
Okay, I'm correct.
It's okay.
Oh, finally.
Ah!
Where'd the shade come from?
Wait, I think I just saw the sun station.
It's so crazy that you could see everything from this, from
like, it's so crazy.
It just, it's, it blows my mind that I can like, travel
this, this universe, this solar system, but also see it
entire, almost entirely from my...
from my home planet.
It's so awesome.
Like, I can just look up into space and be like, oh, there's
those planets.
I'm moving at the same velocity as them.
Almost.
What's over here?
This game is beautifully designed.
Yeah, it really is.
Okay, definitely not that.
Oh, hi, Quantum Moon.
Oh, I remember this is where one of the brittles fell in.
That doesn't help.
What?
Where am I supposed to find this thing?
Maybe I do need to go back to my ship.
This way.
Maybe I do need to fly around in my ship.
Bramble, scramble.
Okay, Addle Rock.
Let's try going to Addle Rock.
I suppose and seeing from there
oh oh my gosh the bramble in the distance it's just so cool
right it's just so awesome and I could be like well a little
bramble alrighty this puzzle is already scratching my brain
okay buckle up buttercup
What the?
Has there always been a teleporter here?
Is it usable?
There has?
Oh.
I'm blind.
I remember going inside there.
Okay.
That'll rock.
Have you checked your ship's logs?
Um, no.
Should I?
Ouch.
Not bad.
We're fine.
Why did I get hurt?
Let's see.
Quantum Moon, Quantum Shrine, Sixth Location, Old
Settlement, The Vessel, Mural, Mural, Escape Pod, Escape
Pod.
Radio Tower.
Hmm.
What am I eating a taco bowl?
It's my dinner.
Remember to wear your seatbelt, Chad, or that could be you.
A radio tower designed to receive photos taken by the Deep
Space Satellite.
There are several photos of the entire solar system hanging
on the walls.
Horn fells noticed something strange in one of the photos,
but included in equipment malfunction was the only sensible
explanation.
Whenever I go talk to him, I'm like, came Mr. Hornfels.
We're looking for Adel Rock.
Or Hornfels.
Whichever we find sooner.
He's at the observatory, correct?
Oh my gosh, I had like a little...
I have like a spot I just noticed on my monitor that I need
to clean.
And I was like, is that it?
What the?
What?
Excuse me!
Oh,
it's going inside.
It's not going inside.
It's...
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm coming in!
Did it just go inside here?
Wait, where did it go?
I lost!
Oh, no, there it is.
What is this thing?
That was so close, doesn't it?
I can't, I can't.
It won't let me, like, lock on it.
It's the planet's satellite.
Oh, it's been here the whole time.
It's for the probe of the Nomai.
Oh.
I was like, I found it!
I was so excited, you guys, man.
from the probe tutorial dang okay where is Adel I think
we've I saw Adel Rock and I ignored it because I was just
like um not you're not my little tiny satellite okay this is
where the brambles Adel Rock
oh oh oh
Hello!
Good landing!
And dark skies, welcome to membership, thank you!
Unidentified...
Wow!
I'm about to set myself on fire, man.
Knock knock.
Quantum moon.
Uh oh.
The sun is looking...
It's pretty spicy.
Oh ha minto!
Press expert.
Lending mode.
Hey, this ain't my first rodeo, man.
I don't need no...
I don't need no landing mode.
Okay, where is...
Oh, here we go.
I see...
That's not it.
That looks like another thing that exploded in space.
Um...
Maybe I should talk to him anyway.
Hey, it's you!
Ground control didn't tell me we're launching.
Long time no see.
Actually, I guess it's been a long time since I've seen
anyone.
What is that you whistling?
I thought it was like, what's with the whistling?
Probably.
Or actually definitely.
The other travelers carry instruments.
So they don't bother whistling.
You can pick up their music with the signal scope.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
Okay.
It's some...
I wish I still had the photo.
I wish I still had the photo to get the angle.
It's time for the meatball.
Bam, bam, bam.
Wow, it's like a mouth.
I, um...
I'm gonna go look at the photo again.
Um...
Oh, sevens in the shot, everybody.
Oh, sevens.
Wee.
Or I can just be in orbit while we die.
Oh, there's an observatory.
We'll just stay in orbit, I guess, while we die.
You could just meditate through this.
I guess you're right.
It's kind of awesome being in orbit, though.
I'm a planet.
I'm a moon now.
I'm a moon!
This music is always a combination of sad plus jump scare.
You can kind of hear it in the beginning though.
It's not quite...
It's a little less of a jump scare.
There we go.
Gosh, could you take any longer to explode?
Come on, son.
Okay.
Let's go take another look at the picture and see if I can
notice any defining
features of the picture that will help me find it.
Okay.
How's my little ghost matter doing?
Don't call me that.
It seems gross.
I don't like it.
Don't call me that.
Oh, boy.
I am on the right track, though, right?
Like, that's the thing that...
Oh, oh.
That's the thing that I'm looking for, right?
You're cooking.
Okay.
I want to cover.
myself with ghost matter.
Takodachi, you okay?
Ah!
What, do I have to go all the way to, like, the black hole
station?
It shouldn't have to be like that, right?
Deep space signal.
Okay.
Deep space radio.
Oh!
Wait a second.
It didn't show up before.
So I was like, It doesn't exist.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, it disappeared.
Oh, no, it's still there.
Autopilot.
Here we go.
I think I remember seeing this red dot before.
I'm questioning it.
Before in the actual game.
It's kind of far.
It's actually quite far.
Huh?
How am I so close?
But it looks so far away.
Oh?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, coming in hot.
Coming in hot.
What the heck is this?
Oh, it's a satellite.
Um, what is error?
Offline.
Is that what it said?
And there's a radio.
Okay, we gotta get out.
Okay, I gotta get in there.
Where is it?
There!
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Hold.
Wait.
Don't
be the...
Play brick!
There we go.
Look.
Wait.
Cabro here, checking in on the deep space satellite per
ground controls request to check out a possible equipment
problem.
Seahorn Fells, I do too work.
You know, I wouldn't mind being a satellite.
See, he gets it.
That's what we were doing.
It's peaceful out here, among the distant stars and the soft
velvety darkness.
But it's...
Oh gosh, I actually really are.
Napoli, nice for naps too.
all right the lens all right little satellite let's see what
the trouble is huh everything looks a-okay ground control no
duster scratches on the lens and no evidence of sparking or
violent explosions guess that rules out an equipment
malfunction after all when you drive you also hit the gas
before you know which direction you're supposed to be
pointed sometimes i do just go Sometimes I do just go.
Also, shut the hell up, Murphy.
I kicked your ass once, I'll do it again.
Hear that, pal.
You're in great shape.
Keep up the good work out here.
My ship is so far.
Okay.
Nice and easy.
Oh my gosh.
Easy peasy.
error map offline okay and what does that mean oh they're
wild adventures um
where's our planet oh Timber.
My ship.
Where'd it go?
Oh my god.
Can't ever find the same thing.
Is there anything else I need to...
Hmm.
Uh, bunk!
Um, let's go back to my ship.
Okay.
Uh.
The silence.
with only your breath against the helmet.
I know, it makes me want to be so quiet, right?
It makes me, it makes me, like, not want to...
I'm like, you know?
Oh, please, please.
Oh, wait.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up,
up, up.
Well, what did that teach me?
That didn't teach me so much, though.
We didn't even get, like, a little entry about the
satellite.
Not to bonk satellites.
What?
What's wrong with bonking the satellite?
Oh?
Uh-oh.
Did I break it?
But it was already broken!
Uh, but it was already broken!
Uh, maybe I should go home.
Um, where is home?
Oh, now I actually don't know.
I was gonna...
Okay, there we go.
It was like...
Only because you bonked it.
Wait, really?
Uh-oh.
Cabro said it was fine.
No, when I came up on it, it said it was map offline.
When I came up on it, before I even touched it.
I promise!
I saw it!
After you hit...
Am I the body?
Oopsie.
Oh no,
wait.
If I go to...
If I go to him, can I be like, I'm really sorry I broke the
thing?
Will he be mad at me?
I broke the map.
He will kill you.
Alex, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh, Quantum Stone.
I did it.
He broke the map.
Oh.
He doesn't care!
Okay.
Let's go...
Back to...
Let's go back to...
So this is the...
This is the satellite we just went to.
And broke.
I guess.
Um, allegedly.
There's no evidence of me breaking it.
Oh,
God.
These balls move on their own!
I need to get back up to my ship.
Perfect.
I think I'm...
I think I'm stuck.
Let's see.
Hold on.
Is it...
Oh, maybe under the map view.
What's this?
Oh, Quantum Moon.
Ash Twin.
Starting to realize why she has DVRs right now.
Oh, Rock's North Pole.
Is a great spot to listen for other travelers and music
with...
Oh, yeah.
Hmm.
Let's go back to the...
To the radio tower, wherever it is.
Just solve it.
Just solve it, forehead.
I didn't see it either.
Oh my gosh, it scared me again.
I didn't see it either when I went out there.
Do I have to wait for like these planets to be in this
alignment?
That's so much though.
Did she find the DLC yet, chat?
I'm trying.
Go back to the second photo and count the planets.
Wait, what's the second photo?
This one?
One, two, three, four.
five, six one do these count as one or two two three four
five, six
one, two three four, five, six
one two three oh my god, this scared me four Five, six.
Am I missing something?
One, two, three, four, five, six.
It's you!
Well, I thought this was strange, but I thought it was
actually...
Timberhurth is right there.
I'm the dummy.
I noticed it this whole time, but I thought it was
Timberhurth that's eclipsing the sun.
Whoopsie.
Because it, oh, it's in this picture that it's eclipsing the
sun.
Ah, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Wait, but...
It's a coffee stain.
So then...
Satellite angle 40.
Common outer wilds occurrence.
You should see play tests with no chat.
I can't even imagine.
Satellite angle 40.
Gabbro.
Hmm.
Do
I have to go back to the satellite?
Where is it now anyway?
Where are you?
Where are you other satellite?
It's not even picking up anymore.
See, this is why I couldn't find it in the first place.
What is here?
Despite my checking on them a thousand times over, the
images are still not ready to print over in the radio tower
oh now they are gabros three foolproof steps for dozing off
oh i dozed off my bad press the wrong button there we go
you can find the satellite using the map the one the map
that i broke you mean the map that i broke
Okay, I'm gonna meditate.
Let's just meditate, I guess.
Goodbye, everybody.
Looping again.
Sorry, watching it spin like that was so sweet.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
The lounge coach.
I hope she breaks it again.
Stop it!
Whoa, what the heck was that?
Gosh, there's some aliens on this planet.
Or in this...
This one.
Hmm.
That's the interloper.
Don't bonk it this time.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Gonna do my best.
No promises.
Where is it anyway?
Okay.
I'm not gonna bonk it.
why is it it's it's it's actually the satellite's fault for
being such a sensitive baby okay watch her bonk it i'm not
gonna bonk it i'm not gonna bonk it
i'm not even gonna get close to it okay it's a little close
okay it's in its orbit it's totally doing its thing i'm
going behind it To see what it sees.
Okay.
It's just like a sensitive baby is all, you know?
Because it's...
Oh.
Oh, it's a good thing that I moved!
I'm getting out.
Satellite!
I come in peace.
I come with no ill intentions.
Yep, I think you got something that I might need.
Angle 40.
On one side.
Oh, it's red.
No, wait.
This display panel right there.
Yes.
I'm not gonna touch it.
How do I get close to it though?
Wait, I went to 47 now.
Wait, it was 40.
Oh no, did I miss my chance?
It keeps going up now.
Is that it right there?
It was out 40 though.
Wandering taco!
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Do I have to go back to...
Will it ever go back?
It's only going up.
Oh no!
I probably have to see it, though, from my ship, right?
Well, I guess not.
Time to meditate.
Ah!
Oh, okay, we'll come back.
Okay, I got it, though.
I got it.
I got what I got to do.
Okay.
Okay, and I understand why the meditating is useful to have
here.
Should have bonked it on your way out.
You're so right.
Okay.
But I might have to take a picture of it, probably.
It seems to be quantum.
So, okay, buckle up.
Here.
This is autopilot.
Here we go.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba...
Okay.
Alrighty!
We got this, baby!
Just has to be at a 40-ish angle.
Ish.
I thought, like, it might say something on the display
panel, which is why I was like, oh, I should, um, you know.
I should read it.
But all it said was the degree.
Okay.
So maybe now if I look at the sun?
My da, my da?
Why?
Where is the display?
Oh, here.
17?
18?
Okay.
20!
Plenty of time.
Yeah.
22.
23.
Wow, it just feels like we're not moving at all.
We're just in...
25.
I'm gonna eat my...
dinner.
A little bit.
Not yet.
Oh, wait.
Let's just go!
I don't want to match the velocity of the sun, though.
Oh, put it down.
There we go.
I keep watching it.
I wish I would...
I couldn't focus on this thing, Ma.
Go, go, go.
Here we go!
Oh, wow!
What's here?
Oh, that's...
Can I get in here?
I think this is a...
A way in?
Kind of?
Nice landing!
Oh, just kidding.
Unbuckle.
Everything is good.
I think.
We're inside!
What else is this place?
New aliens.
Oh.
It's so cool.
I want to go up here, but maybe it's nothing.
Let's go inside.
Okay.
Have a great stream, Minto.
Thank you.
What is this?
What
if these guys aren't friendly?
we just i just invaded their ship unknown language
unknown language okay okay interesting it turns my
flashlight off what's this rotate
i'm on a ship Oh,
and this is how I drive it.
Oh, my gosh.
Uh-oh.
What's happening?
Whoa!
What?
Ow, oh, shoot.
Oh, uh, uh, this is how I drive it with the...
Oh, my gosh.
It's Halo.
Ah!
Oh, we're okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, nice.
That's exactly what I knew was gonna happen.
Is this an existing alive species at the moment?
Wow-ee!
Official welcome to the DLC, enjoy the journey!
Thank you, Jeffrey!
Oh my god!
It looks like a church almost.
Wow.
Ship log updated.
Yeah, I would think so.
Oh, it doesn't.
look so alive after all whoa they're huge we're teeny tiny
they were playing jenga someone who has watched before it
before you even had 500 subs let alone 100 viewers i'm so
happy that you had a successful comeback thank you oh my
gosh thank you thanks for sticking around for so long wow
creepy okay It's like, oh my gosh, the things in, um, it's
like the, the guy, the deer guy in, uh, oh my gosh, why
can't I think of that, the, um, that show that I watch every
Halloween.
Uh-oh, the sun is looking a little spicy though.
Drop lantern.
Oh, uh, cool.
Over the garden wall!
Yes, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Use interface.
Oh, wait.
Okay, nothing we can do here yet.
Oh, unless I have my flashlight on while I use it?
Oh no.
Turned it off.
The council.
Whoa!
They're so cool.
Yeah, it's like a...
It's like the over the garden wall guy.
They really are huge.
I'm a teeny tiny little alien.
These are giant alien.
If I could go the reverse way.
Nah.
Could we watch it together this fall?
Maybe, yeah.
Why not?
I watch it every year.
Wow, this place is so cool.
What's this?
Remove- oh!
Sounds like this is the thing we need.
Oh.
I have to find a way to- Oh, drop!
Drop.
I saw it.
I- drop- oh.
Not quite.
Look at this.
Chalice.
I'll just keep it there for now.
I don't know why I'm keeping this lantern.
It's broken.
Oh, there's another one.
Lenny Muller?
The ambience here.
Already holding sludge.
Hmm.
Something.
Do you know what a reel is?
Yes?
Oh, I forgot about...
I know what a real is.
Thank you very much.
Oh, it probably needs, though, the lantern, right?
Maybe up top?
You sure?
Yes!
Ah!
I told you.
You were on just then!
I saw it, it literally showed up on the screen!
Oh, but if I use my light, it works in the same way.
Interesting.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Oh, I think I just...
Oh!
What does this mean?
Mint, do you know what a lantern is?
Okay, we'll go find another lantern.
Glad to see you returning to Outer Wilds.
Oh.
Oh, that one works over there.
I did truly only plan on doing this in like two streams, but
it might take longer at this rate.
At my Minto pace.
Hmm.
Let's go up into here.
Maybe we can grab that.
Working lantern.
This is my first time...
Oh, my first time I tried using the scout to light it.
Ah!
Oh, see, here we go.
Space.
Little deer men.
In the bayou.
Chillaxin?
Oh, I
think we're fine.
That's kind of scary.
All the lights go out.
Oh, gosh.
It's Titanic.
Oh, never let go, Jack.
Go to the boat.
Get on the boat.
Oh, I'm fine.
fine.
Don't mean a damn thing to me.
Get it?
We could continue onwards, actually.
We have to
get onto one of these, like, as it floods because we
wouldn't reach it otherwise.
Like, no!
Wait, this is the same place as before, isn't it not?
But they seem to, like, always...
Why are...
He looks just like the guy from over the garden wall!
But it seems- these guys seem to always exist in the dark.
Did I leave my boat?
There it goes.
There's that place over there too.
We can still explore a little bit, even though we lost the
dam.
Yeah, they like the dark.
I'm afraid of the dark.
Oh wait, it's another...
Oh, it's this room.
But different.
I'm a little afraid of the dark, though.
Am I gonna not like this DLC?
I think I'm not gonna like this DLC if I'm afraid of the
dark.
Oh god, it's so scary.
Stop turning off my flashlight.
Oh.
Oh no!
No!
We la- I'm such an idiot.
I knew that would happen though.
Because I already saw it happen before.
Because the mirrors are starting to get darker.
What did you expect?
I forgot.
Oh yeah, boom, boom.
Remove slide wheel.
There were more.
Yeah, there were more.
Probably for people like me.
I wouldn't want to see any ghosts in the...
Stop!
I'm afraid of other ghosts!
Any others in here?
Okay.
What's that sound?
Oh.
Okay, I think this just goes outside.
Yeah.
But I can swim.
I'm not so useless.
I can still swim.
Okay.
Where?
I think our boat is gone gone.
Oh, there's another raft.
See?
I mean, I'm afraid of other humans.
It's not so weird then if I'm afraid of other ghosts.
Our boat is gone, gone.
Let's...
So, does the sun not explode here, or is that what caused
the, uh...
The, you know...
Oh gosh.
It's getting really dark in here!
Oh gosh, it's scary.
Is that what caused the dam to break?
I did see the sun through here.
But...
Oh!
No!
You son of a bitch.
I'm afraid of what happens when I take all of these, because
it's getting really dark in here.
It's getting really dark in there.
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
We got the stuff in there.
Damn it, too!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you so, so much!
Thank you!
Oh my goodness.
Why are you guys gifting so much?
I've gotten like...
There was even an Akka Supa I saw before.
before the stream even started.
The eye!
The eye and...
Matara Khan.
Lantern.
I'm scared.
I'm scared!
Oh.
Oh!
They are also looking at the eye.
Wait, are they trying to find the eye tool?
Ah!
It's a motion picture.
They're scanning the eye.
It's a bird.
Hmm.
Ah.
Oh my god, he's observing the power of the eye.
Oh!
He's making the eye...
He's corrupting the eye!
The eye was say so until he happened.
The eye is destroying the universe.
What?
Oh!
And him too.
Nature.
Happens.
Feel loved and supported nerds.
Ah!
We are...
If the eye is against us, we are against the eye.
Wait, so they worship the eye.
See him, then then...
They were like, no, the eye doesn't kill them.
Destroy all worship of the eye.
The eye is evil.
The eye is...
The music is so scary.
What are they doing there?
Something's gonna pop up!
Mitochondria is the powerhouse of the cell!
Oh.
And this is our...
this is our solar system because there's timber her there's
uh there's um there's brutal ha there's yeah there's the ash
twins oh here we come oh yeah eclipse this
has been here the whole time
Next one.
I wish the music would come back.
Otherwise, it's so quiet.
Okay.
Oh, no!
I think that's our signal.
We're running out of time.
A bit.
Oh, our boat!
Well, good thing we got the lantern.
before it.
Yeah, there's another side.
Don't worry.
I'm going to go look at it.
Just wanted to make sure.
Oh.
Oh, uh-oh.
Oh, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, oh, I don't like that.
Why did you take that picture, you weirdo?
What is that thing?
oh whoa whoa oh it lock it locks wait but there was three
eyes in the picture of matara so it locks it if we so if we
stop if we lock up the eye it will stop from destroying us
just for fun we have to get this guy to absorb into what is
going on ship log updated okay at least we got that before
we got eaten by the sun.
Oh, out!
So this is probably of some significance before and pot...
Oh, see?
See, it's like...
Oh, shoot.
Oh, hold on, I'm not done, son.
I'm not done yet.
Shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, there we go.
Hello?
Son.
Um, are you gonna...
Are you gonna blow us up or...
Or what?
Oh!
There we go.
Oh.
Interesting, interesting.
Oh, man, I'm gonna have to go find this place again.
aren't I?
It kind of sucks.
Sorry, I'm eating cucumber.
Oh.
Hey, hold up a sec.
Yeah, yeah, I already know about the launch codes.
Wait, what?
I was going to tell you about using the ship log to set
destination markers for locations you visited before.
Oh.
It's a brilliant feature.
If I say so myself, dead useful.
And the risk of it poses of shorting out the fuel rig.
and causing the ship to explode is so minimal, but only
Ghost Sun would worry about it.
How convenient!
Wow, Slate.
How do you come up with these incredible ideas?
Oh, I do the best I can with what I've got.
Really, you're too kind.
Slate, you are a technological marvel.
Whoa, say that again, please.
That sounds so good when it's not sarcastic.
Anyways, I got a fire to enjoy.
And you've got launch codes to grab.
Go wild with the marking feature while you're out there.
Just try not to follow it so directly you fly into the sun,
okay?
I would never do that.
I would never, ever, ever do that.
It's a stranger.
A massive artificial ring world hidden within some sort of
cloaking field.
It does not appear to be Hrthian or no- and an origin.
A slide reel from...
From the Cinder Isles showed a glowing symbol and chains
appear around a strange vault.
Bless you.
Thank you.
A pair of small rocky islands connected by a village of
stilt houses.
There's more to explore here.
A slide reel that shows the strangers is inhabitants,
analyzing the eye of the universe.
Several slides have been burned and cannot be viewed.
I wonder if we can find one that hasn't been burned then.
A low-lying region near the entrance to the stranger.
There are wooden buildings along the banks of the river.
Oh my goodness.
We have so much to explore now.
Mark location!
Yippee!
There's the stranger.
Oh hiya!
Oh, oh.
Bye, Adelrock.
So if I just go like this, will I reach it?
There we go.
Stranger danger.
Inward!
Oh gosh.
Oh, I have to do all of this again, though.
Okay.
Ah!
We're fine.
Um, yep.
See you guys.
Oh my god, my own footsteps scared me.
I thought I heard, like, someone else walking around.
Flawless.
I know.
Oh.
One second.
Ghosts are super effective against other ghosts, so it makes
sense for you to be afraid.
Exactly.
I see the best landing.
Thank you.
Keep going.
Oh, oh shoot.
How did I do it so flawlessly before?
Wait, no, no, no, no.
No one does it.
Stop it.
Just scare yourself all the time.
All the time.
Javi!
Welcome back for your trip.
Thank you!
Stop!
I did it like so perfectly before.
Ah!
There we go.
What?
Wait.
Okay.
Come on.
I'm piloting you.
Let's go.
Oh, I have to push it.
Um, where should we go?
Where should we go?
Oh, there's so much to explore.
Wait, this is a Ghostmatter.
This has Ghostmatter written all over it.
Did the Ghostmatter also kill them, too?
What the hell is that?
What was that?
Did you guys see that?
It just...
It disappeared out of existence!
There was, like, a little egg, and it was dancing.
Oh, it's that thing up there.
that symbol can we get in at all oh
it's hard when it's sideways no there was something there I
promise I promise I promise be careful be careful that's me
be careful guys be careful me
oh no can I even get
Oh my god!
I'm dead!
No!
I fell off!
Oh my god!
That was so stupid!
Oh man, L fell off.
Ratio.
Oh,
yeah, keep the HUD marker there.
That's all we're going, baby.
Nowhere else to go.
Oh, goodness.
My throat doesn't hurt.
I just can't stop coughing.
Okay.
Check for the egg again.
Yeah, we should.
We should.
That was a dancing egg.
I know it.
Sure.
Okay.
Easy.
Easy does it.
Ah, perfect landing.
Oh, where's the door?
There it is.
Hey, perfect landing.
Nice flip.
Thank you.
There we go.
Yippee!
Alright, let's get that egg.
Oh, push the raft.
It's over there!
There's an egg!
I promise you!
Yeah!
Crash into it!
Wait.
Uh.
I promise there was an egg.
Oh my god.
I promise you there was something there.
It was...
It was dancing around!
It was!
It was there!
No way!
I can't be gone!
Let's land here.
Maybe.
Here.
Yep, right here.
Exactly where I wanted to land.
What?
Oh, did I go by ship?
There was something there!
Oh,
oh, I'm...
Press the wrong button.
Acha!
This is where we were before, is it not?
Okay.
Yeah, I remember all these portraits and stuff.
God, these guys are kind of vain, aren't they?
Sure.
I promise.
What was there?
No, this is actually a different one.
But we need a lantern, a working lantern.
No, you're just meant...
Please, the VOD!
The VOD will save my sanity.
This is a Pandav family portrait.
Look how many they have, though!
Actually, I want to keep just kind of exploring, like, other
places a little bit.
I can't I can't do anything there anyway because I don't
have a working lantern look at them there's pictures of
these guys everywhere I want to see like what this is too oh
this is for the boat okay okay okay Jeffrey what did you put
in mince oxygen tanks I swear there was something I wouldn't
just make that up.
Broken lantern.
Why would I make that up?
Why would I say there's an egg there?
Not mean it.
Wait, um...
Okay, okay, okay.
This is where I was at before.
Okay, so we have been to all of this, then.
We have seen these then.
Maybe it just looked different.
because it was all sunken underwater.
She's not lying, she's just haunted.
She would absolutely make it up.
Yeah, I would.
You're right.
You're a soup.
Yeah, soup.
Thank you.
Says the girl who made up the face in the mirror.
this is new okay I'm not crazy as crazy as I thought the eye
goes whoa okay that's their planet they were like what is
Wow it's powering our stuff whoa I'm seeing everything
Oh my god!
He's grabbing his antlers.
He's so shocked.
What?
Oh my god.
Hey, come look at this.
Whoa.
Woo.
They're really trying hard to delete this evidence.
And so they built their little...
They built their space thing.
Their...
portable planet and they went all the way they hid their
trade secrets it's kind of messed up
and then they were like okay let's go meet the eye of the
universe okay yeah there's three eyes on the matara con
machine i'm scared of the spooky because some people were
like I had to stop playing this because it got too spooky.
And I'm scared when...
It's a little eerie right now, but I'm afraid of the real
spooky happening.
That's another...
So glad you're playing Peak.
Hope your volume is low.
What do you mean by that?
I'm scared now!
The vault is open.
The vault is closing.
Oh, no, not this guy again!
Stay away from me!
Ah!
Oh.
He's going to this machine again.
And lighting it up.
And it seals it.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Why did I stop it on that one?
Ah!
Okay, let's get out of here.
Let's just leave.
Okay.
All right, let's keep going down the bayou.
Going down the bayou.
Are we stuck, stuck?
Push the raft.
Okay.
Oh, no.
No.
guess that works oh why is it flickering that's interesting
it's a interesting effect and then we got our nice music
calm and good okay so that's where we went to before for
sure that is where we went to before for sure yeah yeah yeah
so we We haven't gotten any further beyond this, but I'm
curious what is some of these parts over here that were
under the water.
You know?
Let's check it out.
Little projection cells.
It's just the alien version of yelling audio to all of you.
Ouch!
Beam me up!
Thank you!
This DLC is almost like a theme park dark ride.
I sure hope not.
I sure hope is not like a dark ride.
it's my 30th birthday a few days ago i'm now a decade closer
to becoming a ghost this is the church they burned becky
happy birthday happy birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday
I would clap, but we're on a time limit.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Sorry I'm late.
This is a boat.
Let's go over to this area.
I haven't used my signal scope.
I wonder if there's anything.
Nope.
Makes sense, though.
But what happened to these guys?
Did they get eaten by the eye?
A family tree?
Hmm.
This is so much more mysterious.
I want to go to the top of this building.
But...
I don't know how.
There were stairs that were led inside but there's not
stairs that lead up maybe they autopilot it into the Sun
they could have very possible very probable more likely than
you think okay so these are all just like little houses and
stuff this one was under the water too though they found the
eye directly no my skill issue the It's so funny because
the...
Oh.
Interesting.
Okay, this guy is missing part of his antlers.
But it's funny because the Nomai were just like...
Yo, our guys like...
What is this?
Our guy...
Like, we...
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh!
What is this?
Hold on, sorry, I'm trying to talk and then I'm like,
discovering stuff all at the same time.
Interesting.
My cat says, good morning, Minto.
Good morning, cato.
Um.
What building is that?
And it leads into a cave.
Okay.
Yeah, like a hidden room.
Um.
But yeah, the Nomai were just like, it's calling to us.
But like, I think the I was actually calling to these guys.
Oh, this one right here, maybe.
Oh, that might be how I get inside to the...
To the...
What's the word?
Not the elevator.
That's not the correct word.
The staircase.
Right?
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Okay.
Okay,
this way, over, over, over, inside, inside, inside, oh, it's
really scary in here.
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, it's really dark.
Oh, goodness.
To the cave we go.
We learn about it, we go search it out.
Oh, I was right, it is the staircase.
I've never seen someone bowed into it before.
But that's what they told me to do.
Well, I guess, yeah, I mean, that's what it told me to do,
right?
Ooh, sunroom.
Very...
Oh, I thought the door shut on me.
tangled of them.
So this is an important building, it seems.
Chew.
Oh.
Look, thank you.
Welcome back for two mines.
Thank you so much.
So I'll read a book.
Ah!
Dang it.
Um.
Let's see, what is this?
What is this doing?
Powering.
To the house.
To the tower.
To the hidden hobbit home.
To the grand bell.
It's a good thing I'm up here.
My boat.
I need to get down there, though.
Right?
We have to get down there and then we have to do the lantern
thing all over again.
Yeah, I need to find a working projector.
There's one in there.
Oh, my gosh, we're watching it fall apart in real time.
Oh, it's fine.
It all okay.
Baby.
okay barely a scratch tis but a flesh wound right okay
insert that and let's go find a working lantern which we
know where to get one more lurks Toki do a flip Toki you
make jokes but you'd be too baby to this game i know it your
bird brain wouldn't even be able to figure stuff out
we're gonna be playing this i looked up the game we're
playing on friday it looks so it looks very um i can't wait
for kuso gay all right let's look at whatever the hell this
thing is Ooh!
Oh!
Oh, it's that symbol.
Dokeybird coded?
Maybe.
Wait, oh, let me mod you real quick.
Um, sorry.
Every time I click out of the game, that's what chat is for.
I almost clicked hide.
Hide user on this channel.
There we go.
Okay.
he's looking he's walking who's taking these photos they're
so atmospheric these guys are so dramatic oh he's looking at
the camera ah is that you oh is that you it's me me asking
you you oh
If you remove the light!
Wait, which one was it?
Okay, it's the one where he's staring at Saturn.
Secret title!
This is not a cult, right?
Meep, welcome back.
Thank you.
Meep has been called for work.
Me shall see Devad.
Good luck with work!
It's all of them.
It's anything with this symbol.
Has a secret passage?
I like the footage of all of them.
Okay.
Very cool.
I liked that one.
That was a cool, that was a cool discovery.
Wait, so we can go...
Do it here then, right?
I'd join.
There is no Saturn!
Interesting.
So it's not this one.
Maybe it's the one from up the river.
There was?
No, there wasn't!
Unless you mean...
This one, but it's not the same picture.
Oh.
I'm just gonna...
Don't mind me.
Oh, shoot.
Hmm.
Ah!
Wow, shoot.
Wow.
Come on.
Toast it to perfection?
Yes.
These guys are so huge.
This guy is knocked the hell out.
I want what he had.
He's just like...
This guy too!
Yeah, he took one too many melatonins.
Oh, don't touch the fire, I guess.
My bad.
Well, this is a little freaky.
I guess this answers the question where they went.
But there's one missing and I don't like that very much.
I don't like that very much I cannot believe that I can
roast marshmallows in the in the ghost matter fire
okay this one's no oh I thought it was not lit but it's it's
litty wait did this guy move or was he always kind of
slouched over I sure hope not.
Room for one more.
I'm into...
Okay.
This is not a cult.
Oh god!
Where's the entrance?
There we go.
Sure doesn't seem like a cult.
Not at all.
Okay.
Let's go to this boat over here.
Maybe we can even continue a little bit onwards.
We'll have to swim for a bit.
Okay, nice.
And up.
Not a cult.
Okay.
This way.
Okay, this is the furthest we've been now.
Not a cult.
Nautical.
It sounds like I'm saying nautical.
That doesn't say...
Okay.
Oh, oh, don't fall in the water here.
Okay, good to know.
Don't fall in the water there or else you're...
Nautical.
This area looks a little gnarly.
What's over here?
Ship log updated.
With what?
Over here.
This way.
I like the music.
It plays like such whimsical music every time I'm going
around.
Oh, is there nothing here?
Wait a second?
There's a secret cave!
Right?
Right there!
Oh, well.
It's our time anyways, you guys.
And there goes our boat.
That's our time anyway.
Next to the egg.
I swear I saw something there.
I know I saw something there.
It was like morbbing and then it...
It went out of existence!
I saw it, I saw it, I saw it Oh, I want to go up there Can
we?
Ow!
So close
Not quite
It's really trippy to look at It seems like it's much bigger
too Than it actually is, I guess Because it's just a loop,
right?
Is there a floor?
We'll just ride down the lazy river until we die.
Wow!
Oh!
Oh, ouch.
Oh, God.
I was surprised how much I lived.
I lived just to die.
Can we go this way?
I still want to explore.
Come on, game.
Ugh.
I'm trapped.
Wait, didn't I go to this house in the very beginning?
Oh.
You have boost.
It's okay, I was dying anyway.
I was living on borrowed time.
We did a lot.
lot that time though we did a whole lot look at that look at
that that was a really full that was a super full trip who
knows now who knows now okay let's see we'll do a few more
loops though because I'm still very curious as to what else
we got going on in here.
Ooh, wow, woo!
Okay.
An enormous reservoir with wooden piers and buildings on
both shores.
There's more to explore here.
Oh, a slide reel from the river lowlands showed a strange
vault being closed and sealed with chains and a glowing
symbol.
How?
Who is naming this place, huh?
our own names like we don't we can't even read the language
a real slide reel that shows the origins of the stranger and
its inhabitants several slides have been burned and cannot
be viewed source me a tower that sits atop one of the cinder
aisles the upper floors can only be reached from a second
entrance at the back of the tower.
I found a slide reel.
I don't know why I cannot say slide reel.
That shows the strangers' inhabitants opening a secret
passage in a round room filled with lanterns and murals.
The inhabitants are shown filing into three of these rooms
throughout the stranger.
We'll call them cinder aisles and island tower and actual
names, but the ship itself is just the stranger.
Uh, You can talk to the guy at the museum about the
language, but it doesn't change anything in the game.
Oh, I kind of want to ask, though.
I want to know what he says.
There are small rocky islands connected by a village of
stilt houses.
I found a large metal symbol for the eye of the universe
inside a burned-out building.
Yes, we did.
Yes, indeed, we did.
Oh, wait.
Uh, well, it's fine.
Come on, stranger, I'm coming for you.
I'm on my way.
Autopilot.
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
I'm coming for you.
Stranger?
Howdy, stranger.
Don't be a stranger now.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, boy.
Ah, bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl.
Okay.
Oh, down.
It's forward.
Forward march.
And a perfect landing.
You good?
Oh!
Am I sideways?
How would I do that?
Dang it.
Awesome.
Like a glove.
So why does this thing...
I have to wonder...
Oh, shoot.
I forgot we have to push it.
Why does this thing blow up anyway?
This dam.
Why does it blow up anyway?
Also, I noticed some stuff.
over here, which I am quite curious about.
Look.
The music didn't even have a chance.
Take a look.
Oh, I will.
I will be taking a look.
Damn if you do, damn if you don't.
I guess...
This is the house I was just trying to get to before!
No.
why oh goodness okay that's a boat why is it so dark in here
why is it so scary what's this rotate
okay why is everything got to be so dramatic what the oh
it's just another
entrance.
Are you kidding me?
Another ship, babe.
Yeah.
And it would have let me down this way instead.
Ah!
Interesting, interesting, interesting.
Okay.
Well, fire exit.
Now we know.
That's how you first come in.
Oh, wait.
Oh, whoop.
And push the raft, push the raft, push the raft.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Don't leave!
I'm searching for an egg.
I swear.
It was here.
I swear it!
We still have to find a way to get get inside there.
Oops.
I pushed a little.
Okay.
What was another place that had...
Not in there.
Here.
This place also had...
The...
What's it called?
The lantern and stuff.
Hey, Jeffrey is the egg real?
Don't do this, Jeffrey.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
This is the initial one that we saw.
Drop it.
Wow.
So cool.
Okay.
Here we go.
I hope there's no more dead bodies down here.
Or else I'm really gonna think this is a coal.
Oh, no!
I'm really, I'm really, really starting to believe that this
is a coal.
I'm really...
Really having some suspicions.
This one sounds different, but also all the guys are here.
So only at that other one was it missing somebody.
Totally not a call.
Okay, let's get out of here.
How do you think they taste?
They look like they would taste like chicken feet.
Which I've never tried before, so you'll have to ask Matara.
I'm like struggling to remember where I've gone.
Oh wait, I wish I could push the raft outside the raft.
So we're just going to continue onward.
Chicken feet are good when marinated well.
She like lives by it.
She's just like chicken feet are so delicious, yummy, yummy,
yummy.
We went all through there, so let's just keep going.
I haven't had chicken feet I like I think
Why is it get like that here I did it before also I love the
music on the raft It's so cool So these are the electric
wires Have I gone Let's go over here I haven't really gone
over this way before So Oh Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait.
Please.
Is it too strong?
The current?
Uh, no.
Oh, well.
It's okay.
We're exploring.
Yeah.
Today's your birthday!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear.
Yeah.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
I hope you guys don't mind me not clapping like I usually
do, but like I said, I'm on a bit of a time limit with this
game, so gotta move as fast as I can.
Oh, another puzzle.
Oh.
Oh no.
Okay, we'll come back to that.
I don't think.
I might have the stuff for that, but I'm not quite sure.
The knowledge.
Not quite sure if I have the knowledge yet, but there was
another building over here, so...
Whop!
Okay.
Clap now!
And Draco's thanks for the 10 gifted!
Yep!
Thank you.
Ooh.
Lantern.
Oh.
I don't want any of them smile.
Maybe they can't.
They're like, we're bird people.
We don't know how to smile.
We're bird deer people.
Oh, oh, oh goodness.
Does this just lead outside?
Ah!
No, no, please!
It's too dark, though, if I do...
Oh, son of a...
Oh, it's too close.
Okay.
Oh, are you kidding me?
It literally goes to nowhere.
Oh my god.
Getting spooked for no reason!
Ooh, this is a nice view.
The door to darkness.
Quite literally.
I wonder if you can see the water rising.
So we need...
Oh, contact.
We need another...
Another slide reel.
Let's try going into this other building over here.
Wait!
Literally trolled.
There's this building here, but there's this one right here.
If we just jump right in, maybe we can see what goes on
here.
Can we fix the dam?
Don't launch sideways.
Silly.
Oh, that's me.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm scared, though.
What if I launch the scout and I see a guy standing there?
I'm going to be scared.
Okay.
Sun.
I fire, I fire.
Sun, I fire, I fire.
Sun, I fire.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Oh.
Oh, I could just look at it.
No, I can't.
Sun.
Or is it...
Yeah, okay, Sun.
Eye.
Fire.
Wait, which eye is it?
There's two of them.
No, there's not.
Fire.
Yippee!
Oh!
Come back, Scout.
I thought I heard something.
This game's making me a little bit paranoid.
This game's making me just a tad paranoid.
Just a tad.
This thing's been destroyed.
Ooh.
Uh-oh!
Ah-oh!
Don't worry, you're alone.
That doesn't make me feel very good.
Wee-woo!
No something.
No grabby hand.
Oh look, it's new guys.
Oh, these guys look like real travelers.
Like real spacemen.
It's a password.
Which maybe you shouldn't just have like lions straight
open.
I got in so easily.
No chicken feet for you.
Yeah, it's a chicken foot.
Okay.
Hmm.
I like how they have, it's decorated with their antlers.
They have a nice design choice.
You don't hang up your password as art.
Whatever next background I commission, I'm just going to
have my passwords in the background.
You'll never know.
This was...
I'm okay.
Alright.
I tried to go to that before, and we couldn't.
I don't think I can make it now, for sure.
There's a light up there.
I'm so sorry.
I'm drinking water.
Okay, I wonder if I can get up there.
Oh god, I lived!
My vitals are low.
Maybe I should just meditate at this point.
Or that.
I can't stop coughing.
Why?
Yeah,
I'll get a cough drop.
I think I have some in here.
Sorry.
I might have to call it here.
I could breathe, though.
I could breathe.
I tried warm hot water for that cough.
I have.
Yeah.
Robotussion.
Let's see how...
If the cough drop helps at all.
Let's see if the cough drop helps at all.
I want to make it to that other building that was on the
other side.
That I can't make it to once it breaks.
I'm so sorry.
No, kai.
If I stop, though, if I have to stop, if I feel like I have
to stop, though, I will.
That's a lot of water, not too honey.
Yeah, I have been.
Okay.
If this is how it felt, like, though, when I was...
When I was, when I first got sick.
When I was like, oh, whoa!
Whoa, I didn't even go inside.
I did it for me.
Oh, oh, it's...
Whoa, it's coming in hot!
Bonk.
We're okay.
Just move over a little bit.
We're fine.
Oh, why is it so fast in here?
Oh, oh, where's the floor?
Oh.
Oh!
Whatever.
I couldn't tell where the floor was.
Oh!
Yay, it fixed itself.
Okay, so we're gonna ride all the way down this dam.
Oh.
Wait a second.
There we go.
Ignore the ghost egg.
it's sideways again like meant to do that obviously duh
there's a dock i missed there is where what dock did i miss
hello keep going
you missed the egg too i know you guys missed the egg that's
the first thing i'm gonna as soon as I'm done with this.
I'm going to watch the VOD for the egg.
Yvda!
Thanks for the 50 gifted.
Thank you.
Oh my god, this cough drop is already helping so much.
Wait, I need to go on this side.
So that's the destroyed temple.
Whoa.
This feels like I'm on a, like, a theme park ride.
Okay, it's through here.
Oh, there's this dog.
That's right.
This is this one.
Oh, I can't reach it, though.
I missed it again.
But it's okay.
It's not our destination.
I love this game.
It's fine.
It's not our destination.
Two lights can back up.
Oh, really?
See that?
That's what I want to go see.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Because it lifts up once the dam breaks.
So once the dam breaks, we cannot...
We cannot go through to it anymore.
This sign won't stop me, because I can't read!
It's broken.
Whoa.
The cough drop helped so much.
Goody, good, good.
What's that?
I fell as a chair.
And this one's also broken.
They probably said welcome in anyway.
Probably.
Huh.
How do we...
Is it timed?
Do I just have to wait?
I wonder.
Can a scout get inside?
Hmm.
Let's try.
I don't want to wait until the dam breaks because that'll
take forever.
Hmm.
Okay.
No, I don't think so.
I think every single person I've seen play this, and myself
included, made that joke.
It's, like, so easy.
You know?
Because you literally can't read it.
What a great view, though.
Just bash it in.
We're preserving the integrity of the location.
Oh, well, this was kind of a bust, then.
all the way until...
Let me try getting to the...
onto the roof.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
It's me.
Uh-oh.
Huh?
Something lifts in here and then it causes the dam to break.
Sorry, I tripped a switch to cable.
The flicker is so spooky.
I know, right?
Because it, like, affects the whole map.
Sorry for me clearing my throat every two seconds.
Huh.
So this is all gonna break.
here.
Oh, where does it go into?
Ouch.
We're fine.
Oh,
God.
What's this?
Oh, okay.
It's just a bunch of chairs.
Oh, the council.
Look at, they saved the best seats for themselves.
The sun.
I mean, do you have cooties?
I think so right now.
Do you still love me even if I had cooties?
Oh, where are we going?
Okay, it wasn't a total bust, I guess.
I'm scared.
Yeah.
Even better.
Don't be a freak.
Yeah.
Oh, I forgot to read the ship log after the last one.
The sun?
This is their thing right now.
And I'm guessing...
No, I feel like it would be a different symbol for the eye,
right?
This is the stranger.
Danger.
Yeah, it's moving away.
Yeah, I noticed that, too.
It's like pointed towards somewhere.
Okay.
Minto still going, eh?
Just for a little bit longer.
I do want to get through enough progress that I feel, like,
comfortable that I could potentially finish tomorrow, you
know.
Huh.
What's this?
Oh, okay.
Rotate.
Water?
Oh, it resets it.
Right?
Huh.
It's a long DLC.
Oh!
Oh, it's up and down!
You've got a lot to go.
That's okay.
Oh!
Keep going down.
Maybe?
Oh, we're here?
Already?
Okay.
Don't go.
Don't leave me!
Oh!
What?
It's my ship!
We've discovered a hidden way to get back.
Oh, it's a shortcut.
Let's go.
I think when I saw...
what the what it said for the DLC it said like 12 hours or
something um but
if I have to go in three tries that's okay too though I did
want to like keep it all together so that it's the
information's fresh in my brain but that's okay so far I'm
loving this
I'm scared We're right on top of it.
And it's going to blow at any second.
It's going to collapse at any second, you guys.
This is so dangerous.
Oh, God.
If I was feeling better, I would endurance more of this for
sure.
That's where we started.
can see it leaking through oh oh my god oh my god oh my god
it's gonna blow it's gonna blow at any second now we have a
full week this time pace yourself yeah
i'm just gonna slowly walk across the bridge back to the
house you know just taking my time no rush How do I get back
up there, though?
Hmm.
Well, cool.
We discovered that shortcut.
Oh.
That's fine.
I just gotta get back to the house, I think, before...
Before the dam breaks.
Or...
This thing.
It, like, lifts up.
But so do the thing.
The house also lifts up.
Stand on it and wait.
You're immortal.
Ah!
Run to the house!
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Here's the house.
Does this thing lift up or am I crazy?
There goes my boat.
Eventually.
That's the...
I remember seeing this in one of the...
In one of the...
Slides, though.
Maybe I only thought that this lifted up because the water
drained so much.
I think... I think that's what happened.
The water drained so much that I thought the house lifted
up, but it actually just stays in place and we just couldn't
reach it before.
You bitch!
It's all about perspective.
I don't think I can do anything on here.
Hmm.
Though I am curious about...
About a spot...
About the Ghost Matter spot now.
Is that all over?
Is that flooded?
Oh!
Oh, places.
I had to let...
I
can't...
Oh my god.
Well, let's go check it out if we can.
Hopefully I won't die trying to get there.
Because this water gets a little rough right here.
Let's go check out the ghost matter.
We're okay.
We made it!
This is the ghost matter over here.
What's the ghost matter with you?
Maybe it hates water.
Okay?
Oh, that's promising, though, right?
Yeah, that's actually promising.
Okay, let's go in.
We can go in now.
Oh, no, there's a thing.
Wait, can I pick this up?
Maybe that's not what I think.
These people are just rich.
Maybe.
Ship log updated.
Okay.
Uh.
Cool.
Good stuff.
What the heck are...
Oh, these are the things that they're holding.
Oh, I thought it was a...
I thought it was a slide.
No, they...
are the things that they're holding okay so um there was a
sim what was the symbol in this place that the things that
they're holding would what would you look at that the little
lanterns yeah what a thunk looks like you can get in from
underneath but our ship log updated so i wonder if we're
even need to come back unless
there's more stuff in here that we can't see because but I
think there's also gonna be more I think there's more ghost
matter in there so I think oh oh so I think maybe you
wouldn't be able to come in anyway but I will come back just
in case I wish I could get a boat out
any boats available okay so besides that one other dock is
there any other place that i mean i know there's so much
still left but what haven't we done oh there was another
there was another in the slides there was another one of
these places but it was a hole in the in the ground it was
It was like a little cavern type one.
Still no egg, by the way.
That's because it disappears!
The egg remains elusive!
Because it was literally there and then it disappears!
Quantum egg!
But I was staring at it, I watched it go, I watched it fade
out of existence.
can make it to that log over there.
Oh, there's another ship.
Come here, boat.
Come here.
Oh, oh, ah.
Ow, so close.
Come here.
Nice.
Hey, hey, hey.
No pirates.
Echoes of the air.
It could have been the eye this whole time.
You don't know.
Keep your eyes peeled for another another place.
Another um I'll have to look at the slideshow again maybe.
The egg of the universe.
Wait so if I fall in the water here am I done so?
Am I like, for real, Dunzo?
I wanna see it.
This is the spot that we couldn't get to before, right?
Or maybe we could.
I can't remember, actually.
Badoom, boom, oh!
Oh!
There's so much here!
Wait a second.
Well, time to die.
This will be the next thing we explore tomorrow!
Shabir, welcome to membership, thank you.
I hope I said your name right.
Jump for it?
Okay!
Even
though I really, really want to explore it right now.
But um...
I really want to explore it right now.
But since I'm playing this again tomorrow...
I will refrain.
Dramatic music cuts out.
I'm not even gonna give...
I'm not gonna let the sun have the satisfaction, okay?
Are you still gonna do the direct watch-along?
Oh yeah!
Tomorrow's a Nintendo Direct.
Um, I plan on doing a watch-along because, um, you guys,
there's a little game called Tomodachi Life that I'm doing a
summoning circle for.
And if a ghost does a summoning circle, it is like 10 times
more effective.
So...
it's quite early oh my gosh I just realized what time it is
oh my goodness the stream is kind of early so I'll do my
best it's actually when my alarm typically goes off so
thanks for the stream I love the vibes of this DLC I hope
you get some rest and feel better soon thank you
but uh but um yeah this is usually when I wake up so Uh,
we'll see.
We'll see if I...
I'll make a waiting room for it tonight, though.
I might be a little...
I might be a little few minutes later or something.
Who knows?
CLC is a great addition to an obviously special game.
Glad you're enjoying it.
It's so cool to see how differently you learn and progress
through it.
Right?
It's so cool.
Bye for the rest of this playthrough.
Hope you feel better soon, Minto.
Thank you.
I'm going to rest my voice...
My throat lots tonight.
So, hopefully I can get over, over this sickness.
Man, you can all blame Mataro.
Um, but yeah.
Thank you guys.
Um, we'll play more of this tomorrow.
And if I see you at the direct, I'll see you at the direct.
Do you have secrets for throat recovery?
It's not my throat, though.
It's like in my chest, you know.
That's making me cough.
the though the the um the the the cough drop did help down
with the sickness down with the sickness down with it down
boy down
but yeah um take care of yourself a minute thank you thank
you guys hope your cough goes away Thank you.
Are you watching the direct live?
Yes, I would watch it live.
If I, um, if I make it.
Bark, bark.
Nano.
I'll see you guys tomorrow for more, for more Outer Wilds,
and we'll explore more stuff and uncover more mystery.
And if I have to do it in two more streams, so in a
three-parter, that's okay, too.
I love listening to this though.
Hold on, let's go find a nice...
Let's go find a nice little spot to relax.
I don't want to look at the sun.
Where's our planet?
I'm so short.
I've been meaning to...
the interloper i've been meaning to get the uh soundtrack
for this um when i was buying it again i tried to get the
soundtrack but it was like it was weird on steam so okay
okay ozumito for real message is short i love how stranger
is hid
okay bye guys bye bye bye bye see you tomorrow see you bye
bye